now to the standoff over ukraine about 3
000 u.s troops they are moving into new
positions in europe to support nato
forces newly released satellite photos
show more of the russian troop buildup
along ukraine's borders the military
units guarding those borders are
outgunned and they are outnumbered too
by russia holly williams visited the
ukrainian patrols that would be the
first to respond to any russian invasion
ukraine's border with russia is quiet
for now
we saw a snow plow but no war machines
you've built this as a kind of defensive
position
if someone tries to invade the ukrainian
border guards told us they're ready
though if there's an attack
the ukrainian soldiers say the closest
russian troops to this section of the
border are about 60 miles away on the
other side of the frontier are roughly
100 000 russian troops new satellite
images reportedly show them closer to
battle readiness it certainly
has all the
image of an army ready to go justin
bronk is an expert on the russian
military
if they chose a maximalist campaign they
could pretty much destroy the ukrainian
army as a viable fighting force
for over a decade russia's military has
been on a high-speed modernization drive
weaponry shown off at military parades
and tested in syria
where russia's been accused of war
crimes by the united nations
a stronger military allowed russia to
reassert itself as a world power
now experts say it's being used to
threaten ukraine an attempt to force the
country away from the u.s and nato and
back under moscow's control
back on the ukrainian side of the border
major michael leferen told us they have
what they need to defend their territory
the reality according to the us is that
an invasion would be horrific
russia's president vladimir putin will
be in beijing tomorrow for the olympics
opening ceremony and to meet with
china's leader xi jinping china's
support could be crucial for putin if
russia invades ukraine and is then hit
with economic sanctions by the u.s and
its allies nate
holly williams in ukraine thank you